hey guys Ryan Wright is here today I'm
going to be watching the trailer for a
call of duty black ops 3 the reveal
trailer I'm excited to see this trailer
I'm a little sick right now but I've
gotten blown up with comments that I
gotta check this out so here we go
beautiful
weapons don't have instincts weapons
don't have loyalty weapons don't have
judgment soldiers kill
- into the
what happens when the soldier becomes
the weapon
nice
my green single
deeply how far can we push technology I
could not foresee this thing happening
before it starts pushing back
Hey
Oh
that's gonna be reorder now and get
access to the multiplayer beta let's get
the [ __ ] out of me
that's uh-huh I mean that's cool to know
that the zombie mode is going to be
continuing I like like this dark
haunting future that they're showing us
this dystopian world it kind of looks
like Neill Blomkamp's call of duty black
ops 3 it looks really cool I mean the
effects are awesome the visuals are
awesome as always the gameplay looks
like a total blast I love it so much I
mean there's not much more you can
really say about call of duty black ops
you know it's like it's what we like but
more the monologue though I was really
digging you know that whole theme of
it's not the weapons I make decisions
it's the soldiers but what happens when
the soldier becomes the weapon
you know I it makes me think of several
things like is this soldier getting out
of control is someone controlling the
soldier or is it just the soldier is he
just a lethal weapon if that game can
carry that theme throughout I'd be very
hoping it because that's a cool like
character driven kind of story to me in
a lot of ways but anyway guys thanks for
mentioning that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
because I'm trying to get product
placement when I get a certain number of
followers I can I can do that so help me
make money yeah it doesn't benefit you
thawne Lee hey guys I'm Keith door Oh
awkward name yes that is a really
awkward aim I just want to say I love
watching you guys react to trailers for
games and movies one time I was feeling
rather down and I went to see a couple
of old videos and one just made me laugh
a lot haha it was a Deadpool trailer
announcement to be r18 yes I really do
love you guys your videos rock and keep
it going also please give me a shout-out
I really
want YouTube as my career and I want to
be able to make people as happy as you
guys let's see what your channel is
d'Oro
one one seven he does a lot of gaming
related stuff actually you guys should
check out his channel it's the coolest
channel I've ever seen
he has 42 subscribers and I'm going to
be number 43 right now you guys should
help him out because this channel is too
good to be true
I heard don't quote me on this but I
heard Gandhi came back to life checked
out this channel and orgasmed it was the
most peaceful orgasm ever